this video is brought to you by
manscaped.com
find out more later on
hey 42 here i think we can all agree
that over the centuries human beings
have done some pretty extreme things in
the name of faith and religion
in the late roman empire ascetic
christians called stylites lived in
isolation atop of massive pillars
completely exposed to the elements
in some parts of south india devotees
walk across beds of flaming hot coals
carrying burning pots
digambara monks practicing jainism live
outside all year round without a shred
of clothing
and sufi's celebrating the festival of
hers
will pierce their skin with hooks and
stick knives or skewers in their eyes
you might have had the impulse to do
something similar after spending the
holiday season with family
there's no doubt these acts are all a
strange mix of impressive and crazy but
if awards were handed out for sheer
tortuous dedication
they'd surely go to the buddhist monks
who mummified themselves in the name of
their religion
[Music]
right fellas christmas has come early
this year because i've just been gifted
with the new performance package by
mansgate and it's awesome let's check it
out and trust me your jingle balls will
thank you firstly we've got the
lawnmower 4.0 this waterproof cordless
trimmer is built with advanced skin safe
technology which actually helps to
reduce nicks and cuts on your most
sensitive areas and it has this cool
little led light which is really helpful
for grooming during those cold dark
winter nights
now gents manscaped is no longer for
just below the waist grooming they have
you covered from head to toe quite
literally with their new and improved
shears 2.0 their luxury six-piece
stainless steel nail kit
this thing is really nice honestly every
guy out there needs to be putting
manscaped on their wish list this season
i'm serious or if you've got a special
man in your life that's been extra good
this year then make sure he gets the
performance package by manscaped in his
christmas stocking
because for a limited time you'll also
get two free gifts the shed travel bag
and the manscaped anti-chafing boxer
briefs that's literally a gift on top of
a gift which pretty much makes you the
best gift giver of all time so don't
wait around go to manscaped.com forward
slash 42 to get 20 off plus free
international shipping plus two free
gifts
now you might think that being mummified
isn't all like crazy as you'll know if
you've watched my video on the mummies
of sicily mummification has been
practiced by many different cultures
over the world for millennia but there
was something a little bit different
about these particular buddhist monks
you see
they mummified themselves
whilst they were still alive
before we get into how they achieved
this bizarre feat
let's start with the painfully obvious
question
why on earth would anyone want to
mummify themselves it's definitely not
to get a better profile pick on tinder
nope
these monks were motivated by something
far more spiritual
the quest for enlightenment
now if you're not sure what
enlightenment is it's sort of like that
moment in the matrix when neo stops all
the bullets in mid-air and starts seeing
weird digital rain everywhere
and who wouldn't want that
right
but unlike neo who preferred leather
sunglasses and more guns than an nra
convention
the monks of the shingon school of
buddhism in japan
believed the route to enlightenment lay
through gradual starvation and physical
preservation
by doing this they hoped to become a
soccer shambitsu or
a buddha in this body
[Music]
the practice of sako shambitsu started
with a 9th century japanese monk called
kokai one of the most important figures
in japanese history as far as national
cultural figures go kukai was about as
big as they get and after his death he
was known as kabardashi
the great master
[Music]
whilst most of us would be chuffed to
have someone write a biography about us
i'd be happy with a few nice words on a
paper napkin when revered spiritual
leaders like kakai die
the story of their life is called a
hagiography any saints watching this
video will know exactly what i'm talking
about
except kokai's hagiography claims he
didn't die at all
instead he climbed into his tomb before
death and entered a state of meditation
so profound
his body froze in time and was protected
from decay
weirdly inspired by his example many of
kakai's followers would go on to try and
achieve some kind of spiritual
enlightenment through the same state of
suspended animation
religious texts suggest that between the
end of the eleventh and the start of the
twentieth centuries
hundreds of believers have attempted
sakoshambitsu in the mountains of japan
at least 17 were successful that we know
of but the real number is probably much
higher and many of the bodies likely
remain hidden
just out of sight amongst the peaks
the first known person to give it a go
was a man named shojin who buried
himself alive in the hopes of reaching
buddhahood but when his disciples went
to retrieve his body some time later
it had started rotting a clear sign he'd
failed in his mission
it would take another couple of hundred
years before someone worked out the
magic formula for mummifying themselves
so if you've been sitting there with a
notepad and pen patiently waiting to
learn how you can dehydrate your body
from the inside out
then leaning closer because here's what
you've got to do i'm going to warn you
in advance though
it's not pretty
becoming a soccer shambitsu takes at
least 1 000 days and some practitioners
have done two or even three cycles of
preparation so
yeah best to cancel your netflix
subscription and set aside a good 10
years of your life
if you've got your heart set on living
mummyhood
by the way for any clarification of
doubt if ever there was a time to say
don't try this at home
it's now
anyway let's continue to start you need
to totally change your diet and i don't
mean cutting out carbs the sokko
shumbitsu monks belonged to a sect
called the sogondo
who lived in the dewa sansan mountain
range of northern japan specifically on
and around the sacred mount udono the
mummification process involves eating
only those things that could be foraged
on and around the mountain which meant
things like nuts buds tree roots tree
bark and pine needles
yeah at least it's paleo
for maximum effect you're going to want
to combine your foraging activities with
vigorous exercise just like the monks
did especially in the early stages of
your preparation when you still have
enough energy to actually move around
oh and if you ever find yourself feeling
peckish feel free to indulge in a few
pebbles
x-rays of some soccer shambitsu mummies
have revealed river stones in their
stomachs
once you're living on nothing but
mountain buffet and burpees you should
find that your spirit begins to become
more tough and resolute you should also
find that your body starts to shed all
fat muscle and moisture not only will
this make it easier for your corpse to
stay dry and preserved forever it will
also rub your body of nutrients so the
bacteria and parasites that usually kick
off decomposition on death will have
nothing to feed on
next you'll want to get your hands on
some bark from the japanese lacquer tree
known as arushi
in japan this tree is used to make the
varnish applied in traditional japanese
wood crafts but the sakura shambutsu
appear to have drunk it in the form of a
tea
you'll want to time this part of your
process carefully the tree contains the
same toxic compounds that makes poison
ivy so deadly so drinking lacquer tree
tea
will probably speed up your death
on the plus side the incessant vomiting
will accelerate your physical
transformation into a living mummy and
the toxins will make your body even more
inhospitable to bacteria and bugs than
it was before effectively embalming you
whilst you're still alive
one final insider's tip try to source
some good quality arsenic
analysis of spring water around mount
urdono has shown high levels of this
poison which would have had similar
effects to the urushi t the monks drank
hastening death and making the body even
more inhospitable to bacteria
whilst you're mastering your weirs new
diet the second austerity required of
the soccer shimbutsu was to be confined
to the mountainside three times a day
they would have to clean themselves
using cold water and make a pilgrimage
to the local temple for devotional
practice
not a pleasant experience in the depths
of a japanese mountain winter
but having lived through covered
quarantines you'll already have a handle
on self-isolation so just add in free
cold showers to your day
and you're probably good to go after at
least three years of eating trees
drinking poison living in isolation and
meditating every waking moment you
should be about ready to take the final
step towards your personal mummification
get your disciples by now you should
probably have a few
to close you up in a small wooden box
just big enough for you to sit
comfortably in the classic lotus
meditation position then get them to
bury the box in the ground with a bamboo
tube sticking above the surface so that
you can continue breathing
now all that's left for you to do is to
go into deep meditation and wait for
your body to pass away
whilst your spirit achieves
enlightenment
to keep their disciples in the loop on
what was going on the sakura shambitsu
would keep a bell with them which they
would ring regularly to show their body
was still alive
once the ringing stopped the disciples
would open the tomb to confirm the monk
within
was dead
and then close everything up again
by this point you've done everything you
can and it's time to relax
forever
traditionally disciples of the buried
monk would wait another thousand days
before digging up the coffin
if the monk's body was perfectly
preserved he would be hailed as a buddha
and his mummified body would be
displayed in a nearby temple
today there are 16 soccer shambitsu on
display in various parts of japan the
oldest and best preserved of which is a
monk named shinyakai he was said to have
entered a stage of permanent meditation
in 1783
at the age of 96.
unfortunately though if disciples dug
the monk up after the designated three
years and three months and found that
the body within the tomb had not been
perfectly mummified the monk would not
be considered a sakashimbitsu
and would not receive holy treatment
instead he will be returned to his grave
and sealed in permanently
he would still receive massive respects
though
i mean you kind of have to respect
anyone capable of spending years of his
life eating twigs and varnish
but the monk's quest for enlightenment
in earthly form
would not be recognized as successful
soccer shombotsu was outlawed in japan
in the late 1800s
which means the last person to complete
the process did so illegally
a monk by the name of bukkai died in
but because of a change in laws his body
could not be exhumed for almost 50 years
eventually a team of researchers in the
1960s dug up buckeye's body and found it
to be an amazing condition
if you want to see it for yourself
you're welcome to visit bukhai in the
gasa prefecture japan
sakashambutsu has been compared to other
radical religious practices like prayer
pravisa a hindu rite in which someone
who has no desire or ambition left or
any worldly responsibilities
commits suicide by fasting
but believers argued that sukha
shambhutsu
is not an act of suicide it's a form of
eternal enlightenment
which
i guess is actually kind of the opposite
and it's not limited to japan either in
the north of india high up amongst the
himalayan peaks you can find the 550
year old self-mummified corpse of a
buddhist monk named sanath tenzin
and on the island of kosamui thailand
you can break up your scuba diving
sessions and magic mushroom milkshakes
with a visit to wat kunaram temple which
houses the body of the thai buddhist
monk luang fo dang
if you'd rather get yourself
mummification kicks digitally and happen
to be a nintendo fan you can go and
visit a whole load of sakura shimbutsu
in the legend of zelda breath of the
wild those weird withered monks that sit
at the end of each of the game's shrines
are thought to be based on sakura
shimbitsu as much as it's interesting to
look back on the extreme and almost
overworldly practice of sakura shambitsu
you have to admit the whole thing is
genuinely kind of remarkable
whatever you think to the beliefs
themselves there's no denying that the
level of faith dedication and courage it
must have taken to undergo the process
is something kind of inspiring
even if the results were a little bit
grim
thanks for watching